he's become quite a star in recent days
posing for the cameras after reaching a
milestone a hundred laps of his garden
and millions raised in the process
Captain Thomas More fought in the Second
World War and at 99 years old he's still
fighting for his country who would ever
thought that something like this would
harm from from a little family family
joke enormous enormous Sun and what do
you say to those people who say you
should be knighted but it might just the
Prime Minister is now said he's looking
at ways to recognize captain Tom who's
the envy of his grandchildren with more
followers on social media than a lot of
celebrities I'll tell you what was hard
to watch I'm sitting on the thousand
each has gone up to 60,000 and I said oh
I didn't know what to say it's been
incredible and Tom's inspired so many
others like 90 year old Margaret she's
climbing the equivalent of a mountain up
and down her stairs at home in Scotland
and all proceeds are going to NHS
charities when it comes to those in the
sporting world cyclists Guerin Thomas is
multitasking he's got his fan club his
baby and a bouncer watching on must he
does three 12-hour bike rides on a
virtual trainer there's no down Hills
obviously just pedaling constantly
luckily I've got like I said this online
game pretty much where I can ride and
ride with people virtually but it's
still 12 hours in my yeah Gary
and for those wanting something a little
less arduous there's a five kilometer
run for hero's challenge which has taken
off on social media they surprises that
Olympian mo Farah is the current record
holder it's really turned into a global
campaign then there's been amazing NHS
workers who have finished their long
shifts and sent us pictures of them
running home from work
charity challenges up and down the
country have inspired so many as the
captain Tom more happy hundredth
they sir Rebecca Williams Sky News